la couleur du rosé que j'appelle un oeil
de perdrix
c'est ce que j'appelle le rosé d'une
nuit il c'est à dire que l'on cueille le
raisin on le laisse macérer une nuit
dans les halls b et ensuite hautement
pressoir pas compte d'une nuit russes
avaient cessé selon les années selon
l'état de maturité
le rosé d'une nuit a bien failli ne pas
voir le jour sur les coteaux de l'inde
on ne connaissait guère plus que le
château d'azay-le-rideau les jeunes
arracher le set est planté des arbres
pitié lors de l'entretien beaucoup moins
contraignant et d'un rapport que l'on
croyait supérieur les craintes furent
vives et l'on redoute et que le vignoble
ne disparut aujourd'hui il ne reste que
le dixième de la superficie d'avant
guerre soit une centaine d'hectares et à
quelques exceptions près les
exploitations sont de petite taille
trois à quatre hectares
difficile donc de vivre de la vigne les
viticulteurs en cependant pris
conscience de la valeur de leur terroir
et heureusement la surface on est
aujourd'hui stabilisé
si notre population est le plus petit et
revoir appellation contrôlée de
tourelles c'est malgré tout un terroir
de bonne qualité je dirais même de très
bonne qualité ce qui ne veut pas dire
que tous les vins sont merveilleux parce
qu'il ya des vignerons encore apprendre
leur métier mais est un terroir de bonne
qualité et je pense qu un terroir de
bonne qualité ne peut pas disparaître et
ne veut faire que de se maintenir voire
voir se développer les vignes ont bien
souffert des trois années consécutives
de gel il a fallu remplacer tous les
sept morts actuellement la production et
de trois mille hectolitres 2000 pour le
blanc à base de raisin pineau de la
loire 1000 pour le rosé à base de gros
lot ce cépage typique des coteaux de
l'indre depuis la récolte 1976 ce rosé
classé appellation d'origine contrôlée
les vins d'azay-le-rideau bénéficie de
la traction du château voisin et se
vendent bien sûr le terroir
quand l expédition à se fait dans toute
la france et aussi à l'étranger
le savoir et l'expérience sont toujours
des gages de qualité pour des vins de
plus en plus apprécié les mains de la
vallée de l'ain en général sont des vins
sont les mains femina des vins qui sont
à l'image du château qui sont d'une
grande finesse énumérant d'élégance
c'est ça l'image que je me fais de nos
vins de la vallée de l'ain de lanvin
d'azay-le-rideau